at 6 10 on your Finally Friday what's
cool at school how about a local chef
and teacher who had some unexpected
visitors in his classroom the other day
and they all got to hear from some of
his students
he's a role model to all of us and he
shows us his true value in life Mr
Fisher is very kind and helps students
all the time and makes the class feel
safe Mr Fisher is a great teacher he
helps you with everything that I need
Alexis Daisy and Genesis just three of
the 127 students who nominated Western
High School culinary arts teacher Chad
Fisher he was surprised with the top
prize in his classroom during Teacher
Appreciation Week presented with a
ginormous gift basket by Maggie collisar
from prize sponsor move for less and
check out Mr Fisher's Twist on education
He suggests that kitchen lessons can
help every teacher and every student
culinary arts is the foundation of every
subject where the food comes from what
land what population all this or math at
his track in reading right culinary is
everything
he's got kind of a point don't you think
out of 525 teachers nominated Fishers
the winner gets a 1500 Visa gift card
after a successful career as a chef all
around the world he's been teaching in
the district for eight years the last
four at Western congrats again we always
want to know what's cool it's cool you
got something let us know cool at school
under the Community tab of our website
or just email cool at school at
8newsnow.com